oh hi i
i do that because i would see you when
you were
quite young uh we were in the same salon
yes we were you picked through my hair
to pick
colors of blonde because i'm a natural
blonde
i used to love picking through your hair
what good times
yeah we should do that again sometime
and your mom
is always so nice when i see her
and i i love your dad by the way too
it just makes me realize that we both
grew up in this sort of bohemian
unorthodox spend months
you know at a time in foreign lands
yeah it's a wild way to grow up i feel
like it made me
i don't know about you i feel like you
kind of are
similar in this way but it makes you
like really
adaptable kind of a very malleable
person and you can
be anywhere and i mean that's why you
are amazing on your show
is that you can talk to anybody about
anything you have this ability to kind
of
open your your awareness and your heart
and your mind to people
no matter who they are where they're
from or what they do so
that's probably like the greatest gift
that your upbringing gave you
well thank you for saying that i think
the word adaptable
is one of the most underrated words
because it really is it leads to a much
better life for you and everyone around
you do you
think you're adaptable i do
yeah i think unless you put like a some
kind of standardized test
in front of me i'm adaptable but not in
that
situation because i jumped from school
to school and i was home schooled and i
like struggled so much with homework and
you know all of the things that you're
supposed to learn when you're
consistently in one place
and i was you know living in spain and
budapest and
like cincinnati and it was all over the
map but
it made me love people and love
being places and no matter where i am i
feel like i'm pretty much
good i'm fine and i noticed in the
research i was doing that you do work
very hard on yourself
and you you know you
like therapy and since a young age
you've been self-aware
can you tell me about that because i
love that
i've been so lucky to be surrounded by
people who have
encouraged me to to go deeper into
myself
and i want to just be a good person and
be as as embracive
of others as i can and so i think
learning
about myself and about the even the
psychology of people like
even during quarantine i got really into
doing
online psychology courses because i
never went to college
um because i wasn't going to get into
college
um but i did these amazing courses and
and
i i'll probably be in therapy for the
rest of my life it's like
you never finish learning about being a
human
it's true we have this one beautiful
existence that we know of
and we're here to remain students and
keep learning and improving do you have
a ged
no do you ever want one i mean
i did graduate high school but i'm
pretty sure
i'm pretty sure it was like
really truly by the skin of my teeth
like i think they were like get just get
her out of here
give her the thing get her out of here
and i can't imagine you not
doing what you do because you're so good
at it and you're
thank you working in such a prolific
beautiful way
and in this latest film our friend
you play nicole who is a real person
with cancer and i was watching the film
last night
and i just was marveling
at your performance what was it like to
embody this woman it was really kind of
intense but
but not in a dark way we
and i think partly because we were
filming in the town where
where nicole teague is from and
her family lived there and her husband
matt who
wrote the original article that the
movie's based on
um lives in the town with the girls and
they'd come around to set but this town
fairhope
alabama was so small and everyone there
knew what we were doing and they knew
nicole and they you know say in the
restaurant that i went into
they tell she and matt used to come and
sit here and she always did this and we
remember her like it was just
very very intense and this movie is dark
and painful but it's also
light and silly and funny and that's the
kind of
um juxtaposition that i find in real
life
and for this movie to come out right now
is pretty intense but hopefully it'll
help people to to feel
inspired well it's beautiful
and you're extraordinary in it
and i can't wait for people to see it
you